[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID EUSTIS: All
right, everybody.
Welcome.
My name is David Eustis.
I am a software engineer
on Google Cloud.
I'm here with my colleagues
Ken Owens and Konrad Delong.
And the topic for
the talk today is
about developing
applications on Kubernetes.
So first off, by a
show of hands, who
here has heard of Kubernetes?
That's good, yeah, because
the word has probably
been mentioned a few
times at this conference.
All right, hands up again if
you've at least played around
with Kubernetes, maybe
taken a tutorial.
All right.
How about if you're using
Kubernetes on a daily basis.
Great.
So we've got the whole
range here today.
We are going to be covering
some of the basic building
blocks of developing
applications on Kubernetes.
But there should also
be some new information
for everyone about
how to take advantage
of the new application resource
that we've been working on
to think about
applications as a more
holistic unit in Kubernetes.
So with Kubernetes, you can
manage computing resources.
So that's about
scheduling containers
onto a cluster of servers.
But I think one of the
reasons that Kubernetes
has been so successful is
it doesn't just do that.
It also helps you manage
other types of infrastructure,
specifically
networking and storage.
So if you're building most kinds
of real world applications,
you need to configure
some amount of networking,
for example, configuring
service discoveries so
that as your containers are
moving around in the cluster
they can find each
other, or load balancers,
or firewall rules.
On the storage side, this is
about where your application
data lives at rest.
For performance reasons,
you might want that storage
in a locally attached SSD.
Or you might want it
on a network attached
file system so that it can
be more dynamically accessed.
So you need to be thinking
about all these things
when you're developing
applications for the cloud.
And Kubernetes has a
really nice construct
for doing this, which we
call infrastructure as code.
In this example, there's a
resource here called a pod.
If you're not familiar
with that, that's OK.
The important thing is this is
a simple configuration file,
and it lives in source code.
And so it's in source code along
with all the other application
code that you're developing
for your application.
And that means you can use all
of your existing source control
tools for revision control,
and code review and release.
And that's really great from
a management perspective.
And if you need to be
controlling and networking
storage infrastructure
at the same time,
that's just more of these
configuration files.
And then when you're
ready, when you
want to push an instance of
your application to Kubernetes,
you just upload the
config to Kubernetes,
and it's going to
manage the underlying
infrastructure for you.
So these configs are in
the language of Kubernetes.
And Kubernetes
knows how to manage
underlying infrastructure
wherever that might be--
on Google Cloud, or
On-Prem, or somewhere else.
And so that means as an
application developer,
you don't actually have
to think about where
your application is going
to be running in production.
You can just target Kubernetes.
So what about deploying
a whole application?
What does that look like?
So these days, there are
actually some pretty nice tools
in the ecosystem for this.
Helm is one such tool.
And the Helm community has done
a really great job of packaging
up many common open
source software stacks
that you might want to
be using on Kubernetes.
So with a command like
this-- these days,
once you set up your
cluster, and set up Helm,
and maybe a few other things--
you actually can install
WordPress with a single command
like this, which
feels pretty good.
Or I thought this was pretty
cool when I first saw it.
But then what you end up with
is a little bit intimidating,
especially if you're
new to Kubernetes,
or you're installing
an off-the-shelf app,
and you don't really know
how it's all put together.
What you're seeing here is
basically a list of resources.
And these are the resources
we need to configure
all that infrastructure.
But at this point in my journey
of using this application,
I probably don't need
to see all of this.
And something seems
to be missing here--
basically, where is
WordPress is the problem.
And what I mean by
that specifically,
if I just ran this
command a second ago,
chances are it's not ready yet.
There is some sort of
installation progress
that needs to happen.
Even in the cloud provisioning,
this infrastructure takes time.
We do have that
list of resources,
so what's their status?
Once the thing is
up and running,
you need to connect to it.
So if it's a web
hosting application,
that might mean connecting to
a URL for the site or the admin
console.
If it's a back end service,
you need a quick link
to the service endpoint, the
credentials, maybe some client
commands or tools for smoke
testing the application.
And then that's really where
the process just begins.
Because now you need to
customize the application
for your use case.
And for that, you
probably need a link
to the user guide, maybe some
quick instructions for the most
common operational tasks--
like performing upgrades,
backups, restore, or deletion.
So that's the general
problem that we're
trying to tackle with
the application resource.
So just a quick
note on the agenda.
So we're going to introduce
the Kubernetes application
resource.
We're going to talk about
how we've been integrating
applications into Google
Kubernetes engine, which
is Google's hosted
Kubernetes offering.
And we're also going
to talk about how
you can get started
with these apps
quickly in the Google
Cloud platform marketplace.
So I will hand it
over to Ken Owens.
KENNETH OWENS: Thanks, David.
Hi.
I'm Ken Owens.
I'm a software engineer on
Google Kubernetes engine.
I work on the Workloads team.
And in the open source community
a contributor and co-chair
of Kubernetes SIG applications.
So as a contributor to SIG
applications, obviously
I spend a lot of my time
thinking about apps.
So to start with I
want to talk about some
of the things that
go into applications.
And from a show of
hands, most of you
are familiar with Kubernetes.
Can I see how many
people are using it
in production right now?
A substantial fraction,
so some of this
might be a little
bit of overview.
But for some of
you, this kind of
is necessary to understand
what's going on with the demo
later.
So a pod.
A pod is basically an
atom of scheduling.
It's a set of
containers, some volumes,
and the compute resources-- mem,
CPU-- to go along with that.
Kubernetes is the
declarative API.
So when you create a pod,
you specify those things.
And the system goes
ahead and makes
sure that pod gets scheduled and
create it as you specified it.
So volumes-- volumes
are how your pods,
if they have durable storage,
write things to disk.
They mount inside
of the container
and it just appears
in the file system.
Now, if you want
it to be durable.
If it's not an
empty [? dir, ?] you
don't want it to disappear--
then you need to have a PV.
PVs are persistent volume.
On Google Cloud, that's backed
by Google Persistent Disk.
PVs don't disappear
with the pod.
If you want to schedule a
PV-- if you want to actually
provision and mount
that into a pod,
use a persistent volume claim.
And all that's well and good.
But ultimately, even if
you've got your compute,
if you've got your
storage, if you've
got your mem and
your CPU, you need
to get network
traffic to the pod.
In order to do that,
you use a service.
This is basically your
atom of networking.
So a service basically
just programs
a network to route
traffic to a pod.
And if you want to
expose it externally,
you can do that on our Cloud.
That will provision a
load balancer for you.
So those basic core resources
are like the primitives
that you use to turn up
a workload on Kubernetes.
But they're not
really interesting.
I mean, most workloads don't
consist of a single pod.
And most people don't want
to go through the exercise
of managing pods individually.
That's where the
workloads APIs come in.
So the most basic--
and it's not really that
basic anymore-- resource
for scheduling many pods are
deployments and replica sets.
Now these are for your stateless
12-factor applications.
When you create it, again,
it's a declarative API.
You create a deployment.
You say I want
n-pods, and I want
them to have this container.
I want them to have
this many resources.
The system is going to
go ahead and schedule
those pods for you.
Now, it can roll them
out concurrently--
meaning if you
create five pods, you
may get two created at a time.
If you scale that down--
if you say, you know what,
I don't want five pods anymore--
I'd like three pods, it may
kill two of them simultaneously.
And that's fairly desirable.
You want to be able
to accelerate rollouts
for stateless
serving applications
but not so much for databases.
And that's where
StatefulSets come in.
So StatefulSets are an attempt
to help you build applications,
run workloads that contain
things like databases or other
distributed storage systems,
or other distributed systems
in general-- message queues,
Kafka, whatever you like--
and we found that they required
some additional semantics
around them.
So for StatefulSets,
it'll do rollouts as well
but it rolls them
out one at a time,
meaning that when you get pod 1,
pod 2 doesn't come up until pod
1 says, OK, I'm ready.
You can put traffic on me.
When you tear it down,
you don't tear down pod 1
until pod 2 says, OK, I'm done.
Whatever I had to do to
clean up, it's happened.
You can take me down.
You can move on to my next guy.
And other than
that, the pods also
have durable provision storage
and a durable network identity.
And what that means is
let's say a pod dies.
When the pod comes back, it's
going to have the same network
identity that it had before.
And that's in terms of DNS--
the IP address may change.
But again, using DNS,
it's generally enough
to be able to identify
that pod correctly.
More importantly,
potentially, it's
going to have the same storage.
So if you wrote
something to a disk,
pod 1's disk, when
it comes back,
is going to be the same disk.
And it will be able to
retrieve that storage.
And lastly, you've
got DaemonSets.
So some very complicated
apps, like, say,
distributed file
systems, might want
to do something
like deploy a pod
to every node in the cluster.
So if you're familiar with HDFS,
and you're deploying a data
node, you want to select
the subset of nodes
and say I want a data
node on all of these.
It's kind of a
different paradigm
from just replication,
which is what deployments
and StatefulSets are good at.
And DaemonSets
are good for that.
So now we've talked about
all these resources.
But David kind of made
it very explicit before.
This is kind of hard to manage.
you take all of these things
and plug them together,
and at the end of
the day, it's really
kind of hard to have
a unified view of what
your application actually is.
Moreover, all the tools
in the ecosystem kind of
have a slightly different
definition of an application.
Sorry, I missed this.
ConfigMaps and Secrets are also
something you see commonly.
They're just basically storage
for your configuration values,
map of keys to a map values.
And the difference between
ConfigMaps and Secrets
is primarily that
Secrets are encrypted.
And you also might see
some Ingresses later.
Ingresses effectively route
traffic into the cluster.
And they're used
for firewall rules.
They'll do TLS termination,
and they work at layer 7.
So back to what I
was saying before.
So in SIG apps we
started thinking about,
how can we defragment this?
How can we make sure that
ksonnet and Helm both look
at an app the same way, and that
the GKE UI, and the Tectonic
UI, and the OpenShift
UI all start looking
at an app in the same way?
So all the resources that
we've talked about before,
there are nothing special.
They ship with
Kubernetes by default.
But Kubernetes provides you a
mechanism to extend the API,
to have your own resources.
And those resources aren't any
different in any meaningful way
from the resources that we
ship with a distribution.
So SIG apps sat around
and said, OK, well, let's
come up with a resource that
represents an application.
Let's figure out
what that looks like.
And let's do it with the
consensus of the community
so that we don't
have 20 of them.
We have one.
Now, we're not going to ship
it by default with Kubernetes.
But anybody who wants to use it.
And primarily in
SIG apps, we have
a lot of tool vendors, tool
builders and UI designers,
they will be able
to use it, and we
don't have to reinvent the
wheel from scratch every time.
So it should promote
interoperability
and reduce the level of
effort that developers
have to put into
thinking about this.
So what it really does is
it just groups resources,
describes the
application, and provides
a set of properties about
the application that
are configurable on
a per-instance basis.
So the resource metadata
is just the same metadata
that you see with every
Kubernetes object.
Pods have them.
StatefulSets have them.
It basically just identifies
the metadata of the application
itself in of that instance.
So the descriptor-- the
descriptor group's information
about the application kind,
I guess you would say.
So let's say you have
a MySQL application.
The descriptor
for MySQL probably
isn't going to change much.
It contains things like
links to documentation,
the maintainers of
the application,
or the maintainers of
the underlying code,
some notes about
the application.
Then with info
items-- so info items
are individual to a specific
instance of the application.
So this has things like
the administrative password
for the app, a reference
to secrets, which
is the same thing, IP addresses,
credentials, endpoints,
and other config values that
are specific to an instance
of the application.
And lastly, this is
kind of the magic part,
is the grouping of the
individual resources.
So what this is actually saying
is OK, I produce StatefulSets.
That combined with the
label selector that's
in the application
allows any UI, any tool,
to be able to go find
all the things that
are in that application.
And you'll see this in the
demo that's coming up next.
It allows you to build
UIs consistently--
allows anyone to build UIs--
that are able to discover
all of the things that
are in an application,
and present it
to you in a way
that's meaningful and
application-specific.
And next time we get a demo
from my colleague Konrad.
KONRAD DELONG: Thank you, Ken.
Hello.
My name is Konrad Delong.
I'm a software engineer
on Google Cloud.
I work on the
Cloud Consult Team.
And I am going to
tell you about how
we're making use of the
application resource in Google
Kubernetes engine.
So if you are not familiar
with Google Kubernetes engine,
let me quickly go over that.
It's a hosted Kubernetes
solution by Google.
It's the most mature hosted
Kubernetes solution out there.
It's been GA for
several years now.
It fully matches our clusters.
And that includes both the
control plane as well as
the nodes.
It offers additional
features like logging,
monitoring, audit logging.
And it comes with
a very nice built
in UI, which I'm going
to show you in a minute.
So in this demo, I will
first introduce an example
application.
Then I will walk over
all the resources
that this application
consists of.
And then I will show how
using the application resource
brings them all together.
So let's jump to the demo.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
So what you see on this page
is a list of all the workloads
running in my Kubernetes suite.
And under the name
column, you'll
be able to find the frontend and
the two elements of the redis.
Actually, let's switch back
to these slides for a moment.
Before I show you the demo, I
want to talk more about the app
first.
So the app consists
of two components--
The frontend, which
is a PHP application,
and the backend, which is
the database, which is redis.
And redis itself is split
into two parts on it's own.
There is the redis master and
data-holding redis replicas.
Each of those is
potentially replicated.
So you will see there are three
replicas for the frontend.
There are two replicas for
the data-holding register,
because in this single
redis this master all
that is exposed to
the public internet
using [INAUDIBLE] load balancer.
So in this chart,
every rectangle
corresponds to a Kubernetes pod.
Every column of
rectangles corresponds
to Kubernetes deployments.
And these finding
out connections
are Kubernetes services.
So if we use an application,
and just send it
to our Kubernetes
API plane, we will
be able to manifest the
information that all
these resources belong
together and have
it all shown up for us.
So now let's switch to the demo.
So the frontend and the two
redis that I talked about,
you can see them here.
They are under the name column.
You will see the frontends
and the two redis.
Under the pods column, you will
see the number of replicas.
So you will see that
there is three--
one and two, respectively.
And the same goes for
the services list.
You can see the front end
is the only one that's
exposed to the public internet.
So I can actually go and visit
that IP address and our two
redises living there.
Apart from that there is also
a piece of configuration.
It is a Secret
called "mysecret,"
which holds the credentials
needed to connect
to the redis database.
So now let's have a look at
the applications dashboard.
So in this page, you can see
the list of all the applications
running in my fleet--
all one of them.
And you can already
see that there
is some information useful
for humans to understand
what's going on.
So there's things like
name of the software
and version of the software.
It is not used by any machines.
It is for you to
understand what's going on.
And if we open it, we will
see all these components
that we had to hunt for before.
They are listed right there.
On the right hand side, you
will see the description,
instructions for what to
do after the installation,
and links to the
[? commentation. ?]
Around the middle,
in the info box,
you will find the
structured information
regarding this specific
instance of the application.
So you will be able to reach
out to that service again.
You can even type
something here.
And you can also
access the secret data
that you have to
stored somewhere else.
And again, this is just like
any other Kubernetes resource.
So we can previews it's YAML.
It's all right there.
It holds all the information
needed to render this page.
OK, back to slides, please.
Thank you.
So David mentioned Helm before.
And you might be wondering
how this relates with Helm.
And the answer is
it's fully compatible.
It is just another
Kubernetes resource kind.
So if we want to make use of
it, we just extend our Helm
charts-- this is an example
list file for an example Helm
chart--
with a template for
generating applications.
And then the installation
changes from this to that.
And you just notice that
there is this new application
resource getting deployed.
So after you run this, you
will get this useful overview
of your application for your
applications just like that.
So if you are the only
author of your application
and you have two
workloads running there,
this is nice to have really.
But it really comes
handy when there
are several teams
in your company
and you want to pass
information between each other.
And it becomes really
critical when your application
come from third party.
So to tell you
more about that, I
will pass the mic back to
David, who will tell you
about Google Cloud Marketplace.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID EUSTIS: Thinks, Konrad.
So yeah, now that we've seen a
little bit about the building
blocks of applications
and the new application
resource and its
capabilities, I want
to show you what's
probably the quickest
way to get started with
applications using the Google
Cloud Platform Marketplace.
If you're familiar
with GCP Marketplace,
this is a product
that's actually
been around for several years.
It was formerly
called Cloud Launcher.
And what you'll find
there is a catalog
with literally
hundreds of solutions
for whatever kind of problem
you're trying to solve on GCP.
All of these solutions have
been vetted and tested by us.
And we've made an effort to
make sure you can get started
with these quickly, usually
just with a few clicks
through the console.
Some of these solutions
are built by Google.
Those are usually the
open source stacks
that are really popular.
And we just want GCP
customers to have
a great experience using those.
But actually, the majority
of these solutions
come from our third
party partners.
And we have contracts
with all of these partners
to provide long term maintenance
and support of these solutions.
So again, if you're finding
solutions in the marketplace,
you're going to have a
good time using those.
Traditionally, we've
mostly had two types
of products in the marketplace.
One based on virtual
machines, so partners provide
virtual machine images--
Deployment Manager
configurations,
if you're familiar with that.
We also have some managed
services in the marketplace.
But we're excited to have
announced just this past week
that we're adding first
class support for Kubernetes
in the marketplace.
And we're actually the first
public cloud marketplace
to have this capability.
[APPLAUSE]
But backing up for a
second, why would we
do this in Marketplace?
I mean, we already
have all these hundreds
of virtual machine solutions,
and they work great.
But we actually think
there are some reasons
that containers in
Kubernetes are a better way
to distribute software,
especially package software
and commercial software.
So if you're a software vendor
out there in the audience
or an enterprise consuming
commercial software,
this part's for you
and take notice,
because I think this is going
to be an important trend.
So first of all, we all know
that containers are portable.
So if you find a virtual machine
image from our marketplace,
and then you try and
install it on prem,
you're probably going to
have a hard time with that.
But that's exactly
what containers
would allow you to do.
And similarly for Kubernetes,
like I mentioned-- when you're
building an application
for Kubernetes,
you don't need to
worry necessarily
about where that
infrastructure--
where the application
is going to be
running at the end of the day.
So that's also portable.
So if you think about
that for a moment, that
means if you find one of these
solutions in the marketplace,
you can deploy it
onto Google Cloud.
But you can also take
those exact same assets
and deploy it onto Kubernetes,
wherever Kubernetes is running.
Containers are also much lighter
weight than virtual machines.
So a typical container image
might be a few megabytes
for virtual machines.
That's like gigabytes.
And this makes a
big difference when
you're trying to
rapidly scale up,
scale down to
respond to traffic.
It's also great from
the commercial vendor's
perspective,
because what they're
shipping to the
customer is really just
their own application binary--
it's immediate
runtime dependencies--
not the whole operating system.
And that's also great for
Marketplace customers,
because they probably don't
want that operating system
in their production fleet.
They want to be using their own
golden vetted host operating
system that their IT
department has given them.
And then of course, we've seen,
with all these great primitives
in Kubernetes that containers
have a lot of built
in management
functionality for scaling,
for rollouts, for
failure recovery.
It's just much easier to
manage lots of these containers
with Kubernetes than it
is to do the same thing
with virtual machines.
And since this is
the Marketplace,
and we do have Enterprise-grade
commercial solutions,
I want to mention that some of
these Kubernetes applications
have integrated billing.
So what does that mean?
First of all, it's pay as you
go pricing, which is what you'd
be familiar with in the cloud.
That just means, the more
you use the something,
the more you pay.
If you shut it down
entirely, you're not
going to pay anything anymore.
You're going to get
one bill from Google.
So as an Enterprise
customer, you
don't need to have a
commercial Enterprise agreement
with each of these vendors.
We've done that work for you.
And the fees will just show up
on your Google Cloud Platform
bill.
One thing that we've done
that's really interesting
with these applications is
we're able to support a custom
pricing metrics.
So that means the pricing
for the application
is really tailored
to the application.
So for example, if it's
a database application,
the pricing might
be based on storage.
Or if it's a CI/CD
application, the pricing
might be based on
the number of builds
or the number of deployments.
And this works a lot
better than trying
to squeeze all of these
commercial applications
into a one size fits all billing
metric like core hours, which
is what we've traditionally
used for virtual machines.
And then importantly,
because we want all of this
to be portable,
the metering system
that we've designed for
this is cloud agnostic.
And that means the
metering will happen
whether the containers
are running on GCP
or whether they're
running somewhere else.
To show you a little
bit how that works--
essentially the
applications themselves
are generating billing metrics.
They're reporting those
metrics to a Google managed
reporting end point, and
identifying the customer
billing account when
they make those reports.
And so then at the end of
the month, Google tallies up
all the usage, bills the
customer, pays the vendor.
And that's pretty
much how it works.
So we're really excited to
have some of the top tier
third party software
vendors working
with us for the introduction
of these commercial Kubernetes
applications.
Some of these names you
should be familiar with.
You can see that this really
spans a wide range of computing
categories, from databases to
security applications, CI/CD
logging, monitoring.
I think this is
kind of a testament
to the power of
Kubernetes itself
to be able to support all these
different types of distributed
workloads.
And we're really excited to
have seen all the excitement
from these vendors.
I think they've understood
the new wave of containers
in Kubernetes for commercial
software distribution.
And it's come through here.
So thanks to all
of our partners.
So I'm going to jump
over to a demo real quick
to show you how easy
it is to actually use
these from the console.
So here I am in the Google
Cloud Platform console UI.
We're in the Kubernetes section.
I have a couple of
clusters running here,
but not much else is
running in this cluster.
So I'll go over to the
applications section
that Konrad was showing you and
click Deploy From Marketplace.
And so right away, I've got a
catalog here with currently 27
solutions.
That will be growing
all the time.
Different computing
categories are available here.
If I open one of these--
for example Aerospike,
Aerospike is a flash-optimized
NoSQL database.
You can see in this case I've
already purchased a plan.
The pricing is based
on storage hours.
But I won't deploy
Aerospike right now.
Let's go take a look-- we've got
some other great solutions here
from Aqua.
This is a security application.
They have a couple of
different pricing metrics
based on the size of the
nodes that are being monitored
for this security application.
But I think I will deploy
an instance of RabbitMQ.
So that's a distributed
message queue system.
This one happens to
be packaged by Google.
And so it's free to use.
You just pay for your
usage of Kubernetes.
So if I go to Configure This--
so right now it's got one
of my clusters selected.
I could switch to a different
cluster if I wanted to,
but I'll just keep
the defaults here.
There's some custom properties
that I could configure.
So if I want more replicas of
RabbitMQ, I could change this.
If I want to change
the default user name,
I can change that to.
There are some quick links to
the User Guide Tutorials here.
But let's just go
ahead and deploy this.
So what's happening here
is we're essentially
pushing that configuration
to the Kubernetes API,
the same way you would
do it with a command line
tool like Helm.
At this point, all
the resources have
been created in Kubernetes,
and it's just waiting
for a few pods to be created.
So I'm going to go ahead and
shortcut this and jump over
to the in progress
installation here.
So we can see some
components are still pending.
But actually, it's just
waiting for a few pods
to be created in
the StatefulSet.
So things should be more or
less working now already.
So just to show you
what we have here--
so there's no
external IP address
for this RabbitMQ cluster.
And that's probably a good idea.
You don't want to be exposing
your backend services
to the internet if
you don't have to.
But just to show you
that this is working,
we can do a quick little
port forwarding here,
assuming this works.
So here is the service where the
admin console is being exposed.
This is a neat trick
in the console.
You can actually set up port
forwarding from your browser
to an IP address
inside the cluster.
Cross your fingers here.
All right, so that's
the Admin console.
But wait, I don't have
the username and password.
But thankfully, I just go back
to the application resource
and find them easily here.
So the user name is rabbit, and
the password here is gibberish.
We generated that so that it
would be secure out of the box.
And I don't know why it's saying
that because the login actually
succeeded.
And here all the nodes.
And there's nothing
running in the queue.
But that's-- there you have it.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Let's switch back
to the slides now.
So at this point,
I was just going
to take questions, if I could
invite Ken and Konrad back
onto the stage.
[MUSIC PLAYING]